hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today will be a four-way
free-for-all featuring high-flying kicks
radical stunts and tons of henchmen
passing away from broken arms
it's a martial arts feast for the ages
that pits masters of their domain
against one another for ultimate black
belt supremacy
your contestants are bruce lee jackie
chan
jet li and donnie yen and your judge is
a guy who took
three weeks of karate classes in sixth
grade mainly because mom said we could
stop at kfc on the way home
these four movie stars don't need no
stunt doubles and in some cases don't
even need a shirt
unlike me here's how we'll determine
your winner round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three iconic
moments
then we'll do a wild card round that
will either settle the score or
dig me further into a pit from which
there is no escape the mythological
bruce the legendary jackie the stone
cult jet and forced
sensitive donny are about to step into
the ultimate battle from which there is
no escape
unless they want to x out of the vid and
watch something else that's the only way
so let's get it on round one box office
since all of these fellows are
international superstars we're relying
on the worldwide box office to help us
settle this score
the icon bruce lee might be fighting
with one hand behind his back here
as he only had six films to cement his
legacy and of those
only enter the dragon has reliable box
office data
but it's still a high bar for his three
counterparts
as that film grows an impressive 535
million worldwide total
blink and you might miss a young
stuntman in that flick named
jackie chan whose nintendo game really
didn't capture the kinetic essence he
has
but a chan movie on the big screen
that's still a global event to this very
day
and for his career his flicks have
grossed a total of eight billion dollars
good for a per movie average of 167
million
chan has been a star overseas and here
for much longer than yen or
gently and his voice over his monkey in
the kung fu panda franchise alone
has padded his stats to the tune of 2.1
billion dollars
for that trilogy of animated films it is
me
you bestie speaking of franchises that's
how most americans myself included first
came about
gently he was a boiling menacing
presence in lethal weapon 4
and has also had memorable turns in the
expendables films and mummy
tomb of the dragon emperor all told his
30 movies posed the biggest threat to
jackie chan's box office supremacy
as they've amassed 4 billion total for
the highest per film average on the
roster
at 170 million dollars every time he's
on the poster
speaking of franchises again donnie yen
is now synonymous with the ip man films
oh and he also gained moral worldwide
notice thanks to his role as cheered
emway
in rogue one a star wars story he is
certainly one with being a box office
for us as his roles combined for three
billion dollars total for a per flick
average
of a hundred and twenty million dollars
the deeper you get into yen and jetley's
catalogues reveal
just how massive their films are
including ones that might not have made
much of a financial impact
stateside however the same could be said
for jackie chan
whose films were cult hits in the united
states until he burst out with rumble in
the bronx
and for every giant hit we know of like
the rush hour trilogy of films
he's also done films like gongfu eugea
which earned 266 million dollars
he's simply been raking in cinematic
bread for longer
and just about as efficiently as any
superstar period
and he can at least put the beach boys
on my radio anytime he wants i love his
bullets
jackie chan wins the round and is off to
a one to nothing
to nothing to nothing lead that's right
i'm the master
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
jackie surges to an early lead but
whereas career length and volume could
help in round one
too many rotten movies could be a
penalty for the tomato meter section
brace yourself kiddies jackie chan has
been incredible in each and every one of
his 54 movies which graced the tomato
patch
but he's also the only actor here who
has a rotten average
clocking in at a very respectable 54
with critics
and 57 percent for his audience score
what's more amazing is how healthy this
entire cast of legends is with both
metrics
bruce lee's six films get him the
highest overall average
at 77 percent on the tomato meter and 75
for the audience score both measurements
agree that enter the dragon is his best
work
as it's at 92 percent and 90
respectively
in fact his only rotten outing on the
tomato meter is his last work
game of death which feels a tad unfair
he passed away during production
and stand-ins were used to complete the
movie so now pressure's on donnie yen
and jet li to take on the man
the myth the dragon
but jet li has got some legendary fists
or at least one fist although i bet he's
pretty ambidextrous
i digress fist of legend is his crown
jewel in the tomato meter garnering a
perfect 100 and helping his overall
average to a fresh
60 over 30 films crowds love him even
more
as his audience scores at 66 percent
even lower rated flicks like cradle to
the grave the one or white snake feature
so much lee badassery they're hard to
resist
but i can confidently recommend hero
which is tied atop his tomato meter
at 95 percent but jet li
he ain't the only star of that movie
ladies and gentlemen donnie yen is also
in hero
however that only earns the silver medal
in his filmography
as ip man two leads the way at 96
percent atop the tomato meter
other top fives in yen's library include
once upon a time in china 2
at 92 percent and ip man 4 at 87 percent
damn this dude's sequels even do well
with critics oh and i'm getting word now
that
yes i can confirm gently also appears in
once upon a time in china too
which makes this call even tougher
donnie has 26 films total here and he
boasts the same 65
fresh average on both critical and
audience scales
and although he does go all the way down
to 11 rotten for a highlander end game
he was the best part of that movie he
put the whole damn thing on his back
there can be only one and it should have
been him well at least
in this round he appears to be the one
wait that's a gently movie
damn it okay look donny's got the higher
average that's my story and i'm sticking
to it
yen wins the round and is on the board
but i have a feeling we haven't heard
the last from jet li
round three iconic moments so we have
four of the baddest men to ever walk
run or jump kick on planet earth and now
we only have one round to determine
who's given us the most enduring moments
in cinematic martial arts history
no don't worry we sold the wild card
round too well you could be here for a
while and that's not even counting
all those great jackie chan outtake
scenes chan gets an early lead here as
he not only can kick ass
he can be genuinely hilarious when doing
so
and on purpose not like steven seagal
playing acoustic guitar kind of way
and while the rush hour trilogy makes
for good showcases of all these talents
i'd also point to his work opposite owen
wilson in shanghai nights for big action
and hearty guffaws if it's more straight
up action you dig
chan has plenty of that in stock too the
catch maneuver and snake in the eagle
shadow
and the coal fight and legend of drunken
master and highlights
and he also takes on a whole army in
that movie
a whole army my personal favorite of
chance is my soft spot for rumble in the
bronx
the market fight showcases the guy
willing to do anything to entertain us
even if it leaves his body battered
bruised
or stuck in a ladder he actually broke
his ankle performing one of the stunts
in that movie
the forbidden kingdom also features
intense battles between chan
and our next competitor jet li
we skills are legendary and what really
separates him from the pack
is his willingness to fight anyone
including fellow martial arts masters
and movie stars
his introduction to many americans was
him beckoning on mel gibson and danny
glover in lethal weapon four
and he's arguably the best part about
that movie sorry chris rock
he also takes on ivan drago himself in
the expendables
and goes toe-to-toe with jason statham
in war but for pure league greatness
i'd point you towards kiss of the dragon
when it's him taking on a different
skill
set in boxing the atmosphere becomes
electric and that's the same flick where
he battles the twins
no no no i don't mean arnold
schwarzenegger and danny devito [ __ ]
lee's superior quickness and reflexes
match with so well against donnie yen in
both hiro
and once upon a time in china too but
for my money
and you can tell how i dress that i'm
loaded i'm going with gently
and fearless the end tournament
basically makes me want to train in
martial arts
and reminds me i'll never get close to
being that good at anything
but i am decent at star wars trivia so i
knew donnie yen would be an amazing
addition to the galaxy far
far away canon and he didn't disappoint
he's so effortless in his ability to
dominate a gaggle of stormtroopers in
one scene
and then calmly explained his oneness
with the force in the next
i knew he'd be great at the sci-fi
action i wasn't prepared for how much
deeper he'd make me consider my own
religion
yes i am a jedi like my father before me
but if you bring up donnie anne you've
got to give some love to it man
the first film in the franchise sets the
tone with a well-choreographed brawl
against louis fan
and then in ip man 4 we get another true
badass when it's yen taking on scott
adkins not of the adkins diet but i'm
willing to bet dude does keto
perhaps the longest and most brutal
battle in ip man war
is in the second film when donnie is
pitted against samo hong
whether it's a rad vehicle chase with
vin diesel and triple x
or a very different spin on tic-tac-toe
in drunken tai chi
donnie yen continually proves he's not
just a star
he's the embodiment of martial arts
philosophy
which brings us to the man who inspired
so many to take up the ancient arts
bruce lee i love the big boss fights
because they teach us that sometimes you
need a good defense before you can go on
the attack
the disarming knife fight is so well
done as is the final battle
and years before a new generation
learned what nunchucks were from a party
dude turtle
lee took us all to school in his last
film game of death
[Music]
while we're on the topic of school i
don't think i'd pick too many fights at
karate class i'd rather just watch
fist of fury again
enter the dragon might be the gem for
bruce lee battles the basement fight and
lee quickly dispensing of o'hara still
hold up to this day
but there's no way i can leave this
round before reminding everyone that
bruce lee
barely broke a sweat against yep you
guessed it
chuck freaking norris the toughest man
on earth or mars whose chin alone has
sent 38
000 people to the er walker texas ranger
oh and while you're recovering from that
we also defeated the nba's all-time
leading scorer
no it's not michael jordan no it's not
lebron james kareem abdul-jabbar
or in your basketball history kids or go
watch airplane
i'm the co-pilot but for all of the
iconic moments bruce lee delivered
for me this category is simply about who
would i rather watch fight
on screen the most every one of these
talents is worthy of your box office
money
but gently is my go-to for controlled
intensity
masterful focus and lightning quickness
he can also act whether it's as a noble
hero or a menacing villain
he may not have the comedic timing of
jackie chan or the serene presence of
donnie yen
but pound for pound gently is my best
bet for delivering mesmerizing scenes
of pure martial artistry round three
goes to him
and now it's time for the wild card
round
now it's time for said wild card round
legacy
since we're talking about movies
featuring centuries-old fighting
techniques we might as well figure out
who people will be talking about
centuries from now
all of these gents will have a place in
cinema lore with good reason
i could attempt to summarize what jet li
has meant to both the asian pacific
american community
and the world at large but it's more
accurate to hear his words
the message of hero is that the
suffering of one person can never be as
significant as the suffering of a nation
unleashed shows us that violence is
never a solution and fearless
tells us that the biggest enemy of a
person could be themself
according to lee the greatest weapon is
a smile
and the largest power is love without a
doubt one of the biggest reasons we love
jackie chan
is his smile he feels like an everyman
without trying to be
yet we can still buy into it when he can
beat the crap out of everyone around him
and sometimes himself in the process the
police story movies
best show what chan is all about
entertainment
at any cost his stunts are absolutely
bonkers in that film but he also reveals
his heart it's the magical elixir of
affability
risk-taking and kung-fu artistry that
makes jackie chan
the most unique of actors and it's
probably why we'll always show up in
droves to watch his movies
donnie yen's star power certainly arose
in the united states after his winning
turn in rogue one but his legacy
had already been cemented thanks in
large part to the success of the ip-man
franchise but will also give anyone
kill zone to watch come back after
seeing that and name anyone that could
mess with donnie yen
his embracing of mma makes him
competitive in this round as his fight
scenes feel
authentic with moves you could see on
fight island any given saturday night
oh and if it's street cred you want yen
once reportedly put
eight guys in the hospital because they
were harassing his girlfriend
he's one with a force but if you mess
with this lady it's a different story
and it's a quote from jen's website that
leads us to our final challenger
i take martial arts into a whole
philosophy i respect bruce lee so much
because his whole martial arts
is about the way to live bruce lee
embodied not just what it means to be an
action movie star
he cultivated an aura around him that
was part badass
part gentle soul all real lee's parents
got him off the streets and
into organized competition thanks to
martial arts legend yip man
in fact bruce lee was so versatile in
one year he won a boxing competition
and a cha-cha dance-off that folks
is range but mystery and tragedy also
contribute to the legacy of bruce lee
we'll inevitably always ask what could
have been about a talent that the world
lost
so young the same could be said for his
son brandon
that's certainly fair but let's not lose
sight of what he gave us all before his
passing
a new way to look at movies sure but
also a fresh approach to life
recently the documentary b water
provided new insight into the
development
matriculation and career of bruce lee
and in the process
acted as further evidence why this man
was so crucial to the martial arts
actors that would follow
it's too easy to say bruce walked so
donnie yen jackie chan and gently could
run
because bruce also ran and despite the
unfortunate fact that his was a sprint
and not a marathon
it doesn't dull any of the shine from
bruce lee's legacy
he wins the round emphatically i mean
again he did beat up chuck norris
and we have us a good old-fashioned
four-way
not not that kind of four-way it's not
right
and since each combatant won a round in
today's show
they all have a credible case as to why
they should win the whole thing
is bruce lee's gigantic shadow big
enough to conquer all foes
or perhaps it's jetley's skill or
danien's philosophy that could put them
over the top
my winner is none of them it's jackie
chan
i don't know who i take in a street
fight but i know who the most
entertaining brawler would be
and that's jackie chan it's impossible
to overstate how appealing jackie chan
can be
without even uttering a single line of
dialogue it doesn't matter if it's his
fists
her feet or face taking the weed when
he's on screen
you probably shouldn't attempt to blink
his sense of humor
especially when it comes to
self-deprecation make him relatable to
us in a way few stars ever have
here we have one of the greatest talents
cabba has ever seen
yet he has problems and makes mistakes
blubs like anybody else
celebrities hey they're just like us
jackie isn't really like us but he never
fails to bring us along for the ride
bruce lee donnie yen and jet li all
fought well and made strong cases
and i'm so happy i don't have to choose
a silver medalist today jackie chan
is your winner
[Applause]
that's dope isn't it keep making movies
jackie
just don't hurt yourself too much and if
you do make sure it's in the outtakes
during the credits
i'm mark ellis none of my flubs are
gonna be in these outtakes and i'll see
you next time on versus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you